hello I'm your last speaker of the day I
know that that makes you happy uh and uh
I'm delighted to be here and many thanks
to bagie uh I am going to talk about
multicurrency
mercantilism and this is the scary idea
that the world moves away from the US
dollar which was
87% of all Global transactions in
2021 but something broke in 2022 and now
most of the world 80 countries have
decided that they are moving to local
currency trade in their own currencies
and away from the US
dollar now my background I started out
at the place that creates the dollar the
Federal Reserve Bank of New
York and I was on the settlement systems
studies group then I went and I
dematerialized Securities in London for
the Securities and Investments board and
I supervised the two global depositories
Euro clear and clear stream and then I
decided the systems we have aren't good
enough I'm going to build new ones I
mean it's been great today listening to
you guys talk about networks and Charter
cities and change because I've done all
that um I went to clear stream where I
got us treasuries into Luxembourg
globalized US treasuries US dollar
liquidity uh I co-invented Tri party
repo that now does $18 trillion a day in
inbank secured
credit uh I I built the first Global uh
derivatives margin optimization and got
the patent on it yay I then went
independent because I had I had babies
so I went from my most productive period
to a reproductive period and um and I
built CLS Bank as my first job as a
consultant that is now a foreign
exchange Clearing House that clears 7.5
trillion a day in foreign exchange
settlements $1,900 trillion a year
um I then modernized Reuters UBS into
three global data centers as a weird
favor for Andrew Bailey who's now
governor of the bank of England I built
a payment system in postwar Iraq that
went live in 10 weeks using data over
satellite and
laptops
um um and then uh you know Charter City
hey been there done that tick that box
Dubai International Financial Center um
I went out in May of 2005 NASDAQ Dubai
went live in September we wrote the laws
we wrote the governance we wrote the
rule books we got all of the banks on
board we wrote the settlement in uh
infrastructure the gate was the only
building in DFC when I arrived just
desert all around and now it's a huge
City so yeah Charter cities they work um
and I've won I've modernized uh 14
central banks with intellect design
Arena um getting a central bank award
yay so that's where I am now I am also a
founder of a fintech startup that's
building the new Global monetary order
so I'm going to walk you through how
that's going to work basically uh when
the last monetary order Breton Woods was
designed in 1944 the United States had
80% of all Global gold the largest
military dominant military on the planet
and most of the GDP half of all world
GDP that's no longer true none of it now
the greatest economic activity is in
Asia that Yuji Circle has more than half
of humanity in it and they're growing at
between 5 and 8% and they want a
monetary order that suits
them so the world's changing I'm not
going to run through the history
but give you know history is changing
very very fast so now we're at the new
monetary order which I called
multicurrency mercantilism when I
Googled it zero hits well I didn't think
there were two words in English that
could get zero hits um but the reason
it's mercantilist is because the aim of
a mercantilist system is for a state a
nation to collectively increase its
wealth through trade through activity
with other states a capitalist system
the aim is for private wealth to
accumulate often untaxed and
stateless so that's the difference
between mercantilism and
capitalism and last year changed
everything because the 12,000 sanctions
that the collective West put on Russia
broke the system other states looked at
those sanctions and they thought we have
to defend ourselves we have to defend
our wealth from freezing seizure
expropriation and the way to do that is
to move away from the dollar and the key
moment was in December of last year when
President X stood with the six heads of
state of the gulf cooperation Council
and invited them to trade oil in
Shanghai for Yuan ending 50 years of the
Petra
dollar so my I'm going to give you the
happy news this is all good it's going
to be okay I know that the the United
States the Federal Reserve the treasury
all terrified and yes it's going to
change for them there will be a new
balance of power but for the rest of the
world for the seven billion people that
have been largely voiceless and in the
institutions that ran the world under
the dollar they are going to be actually
much much better off and the transition
can be gradual and stable it really
depends on whether we have wider Wars
unfortunately if there's a war in the
Levant that widens from Gaza if there's
a war in Asia Asia over Taiwan or any
other cause this the the transition will
still happen it will accelerate but it
will become chaotic and unpredictable so
we're all better off if there's no war
um the reason the reason that can be
transition yes no more thank you um uh
the reason it can be stable I'll just
run you through the
numbers all global trade and goods we're
talking about physical things all global
trade and goods 46 trillion
now I told you earlier Foreign Exchange
Trade is
$1,900
trillion so 46 trillion is a very small
part of that and only half of that is
dollar trade right now so that's 26
trillion so if let's say half of the
dollar trade moves to local currency
over the next decade that's only 11 and
a half
trillion
uh oh was 23 trillion was yes um so 46
trillion trade 23 trillion dollars 11.5
trillion moves to local currency trade
as a proportion of global Capital
markets flows it's only about
0.04% not very
much why we probably won't even notice
it unless there's a war and the the
shift becomes chaotic and the Capital
Market become
destabilized as long as there's no
further Wars the capital markets will
continue to trade mostly in dollar
because 90% of the Foreign Exchange
Trade is against dollar most derivatives
margin is in dollar most bond market the
treasuries are the largest bond market
and their dollar so as long as there's
no war the rest of the capital markets
can remain stable and we don't have to
have a
panic great thing about the new world
that's coming no new haimon we still
have the United States the United States
will still try and throw its weight
around by Wars assassinations
destabilizations and all of that that
it's characterized the last 100 years
but the 80 countries moving towards a
new world don't want a new hegemon and
certainly president XI said at the
latest brick Summit that there is no
hegemonic DNA in China that China for
5,000 years has never been hegemonic and
it's not going to be hegemonic
now so that's good
news globalization will accelerate we
hear all this stuff about drisking about
uh friend Shoring it's
nonsense globalization actually is going
to accelerate as the brics countries and
the other countries of the global South
do more joint development deals with
each
other and substitute other currencies
instead of dollar right now 30% of the
global economy is locked out of the
global economy because of dollar
sanctions and ofac
sanctions those that 30% which is Iran
Russia Syria uh Venezuela Cuba those
countries can come in and engage with
the non-dollar world so that shifting to
other currencies besides dollar means
that they actually accelerate
globalization and that's a happy thing
and and and then initiatives like the
the belt and Road initiative are having
huge effect on the the capacity for
productivity
globally because there's more power
plants because there's better Logistics
because there's more cooperation on
development it's accelerating
globalization Angel Paradox named for
sir Norman angel I'm a big fan of his
I've rented his house three times um he
built it from bits of Driftwood that he
salvaged um he won the not no 1932 Nobel
Prize Nobel Peace
Prize for the
Insight that when developed economies
independ sorry dependent interdependent
developed economies go to war and impose
economic sanctions on each other that
the costs are shared between the
sanction and the sanctioned that both
lose because when you sanction
somebody's credit or contracts and
disrupt
Commerce that affects the value of all
of your own credits contracts and
commerce and we've seen this so clearly
in 2022 where uh treasuries have now
lost their AAA credit rating and uh
people are uh avoiding accumulating
treasuries because of the sanctions risk
so it's got Janet Yellen worried it's
got J pal worried and they should be
worried but the the answer is don't
sanction and and we've also seen
incredible blowback for the technology
sanctions on China where uh Huawei has
built an entirely new technology
ecosystem in three years because of
sanctions um and announced their new
phone which includes satellite
connectivity while Gina randoo was in
Beijing so the great news is there are
better models for stability resiliency
and inflation in the world that's
coming
we may not like Russia we may not like
China I actually think they're fine but
they have actually cracked monetary
stability much better than the Federal
Reserve the bank of England and the
ECB and Chinese bonds have been
outperforming us
treasuries uh which is really quite
impressive uh they're not a big Market
they don't trade much outside of China
but the fact is that there are other
models for inflation for stability
beyond what we agree on in basil and
that I think uh deserves study and the
new system where we move to local
currency trade can promote that
um Ghana announced earlier this year
that it was going to buy its oil for
gold they produce gold they have gold
central banks love gold 2023 is a record
year for Central Bank gold accumulation
so Ghana thought well why don't we buy
the oil we need with gold their
inflation rate dropped
by more than 80% from the
announcement so the inflation rate is
still pretty high it's like 30 something
percent but compared to where it started
the year at 169% um it's it's a vast
Improvement so new systems that are
based on barter or other currencies can
actually help countries control
inflation promote
development and finally the gold
standard was absolutely a brilliant way
to control inflation if we go back to
Gold it's probably good for us uh the
the graph there shows the price of a
Campbell Soup can uh in Gold up until
1971 it was pretty much absolutely
stable but as soon as Nixon delink from
gold the United States has had nothing
but
inflation and so if we go back to gold
as the basis of international monetary
discipline that's probably
good so gold comes back as a honic
asset uh and we see the the little
cartoon is representing the fact that um
that that China is hurling its dollars
at the United States the United States
is hurling gold back at China Gold is
Flowing East there have been record
purchases of gold this year China has
been buying gold every month and and
announcing it to the world uh and they
are um uh not buying treasuries quite so
much anymore they're down to the same
level of treasuries they held in 2008 at
87 billion they've been reducing their
exposure
so gold demand is up among central banks
and that indicates the direction of
travel because they are the
Insiders the biggest challenge to making
the transition stable is
debt uh there are $37 trillion of debt
in issuance and that debt is becoming
very expensive to Service as interest
rates rise uh Emerging Markets are
feeling the pain because a lot of their
borrowing is in dollars and they aren't
able to service at the at the rising
rates so there is going to be a big
problem in making the transition stable
and keeping growth positive and
servicing debts I don't know how that
works but I think we have to collaborate
on it finally good news on technology
and infrastructure the future is here
it's just not evenly
distributed I built some of it you know
I built I built the trip party repo
system that in that is the interbank
market in liquidity I want to globalize
that to every currency I globalized
dollars a lifetime ago his name is Mason
um I want to globalize every currency to
be liquid in the interbank markets
now and that then creates a basis for
more Equitable world where wealth
doesn't concentrate with the
0.1% wealth can be more evenly
distributed to those that produce
it and as the world's Center of economic
gravity moves
eastwards now is the time to make that a
reality so thank you if you like that I
just published the book
yesterday